what's going on guys welcome back to the
cosmic wonder I'm your host Chris and
today we have an extremely interesting
news I miss all of the insane changings
over at Disney starting with
specifically and I'm sure you've heard
Bob chapek stepping down or we'll call
it being replaced or fired and Bob Iger
returning to take over CEO and chairman
of Disney now it's very heavily
speculated that the reason for this
happening is because the board wasn't
happy with jpex decisions the direction
that Disney was headed and its overall
success from the last few years and yes
covet happened and many different
companies are struggling but if you look
at Disney's projection over the last
five years they're headed downwards and
with Disney being as big of a company as
it is there are going to be a lot of
people who aren't happy with the current
trends Disney's having so it's possible
that Bob iger's return to Disney as CEO
as chairman as the big boss isn't simply
to right the ship during his two years
that he signed on and then find a
replacement but perhaps it's to sell
Disney altogether we'll be talking about
this news in today's video but first be
sure to subscribe if you haven't already
and turn on that notification Bell so
you don't miss out on our daily Marvel
updates and yes of course this is a
Marvel update why Disney owns Marvel
Studios in fact Marvel Studios is one of
the many companies over the last 10 15
years that Disney has acquired companies
like GoPro Star Wars Pixar and of course
Marvel Studios along with many many
others have all been picked up and
brought into the fold under the belt of
Disney property and that's something
that Bob Iger was very very well known
for during his tenure while he was in
charge of Disney but then he stepped
back and we got a new CEO who the board
wasn't happy with Bob iger's back and
and what's the plan well there are a few
insiders who say he's going to sell the
company these are direct quotes coming
from Anonymous sources saying that the
plan is for Iger to completely wash out
Disney and to sell it out to somebody
else so that they can have the money and
the opportunities to continue Building
forward to a successful future now this
is not an uncommon thought coming from
Bob Iger why well specifically in igers
2019 autobiography the ride of a
lifetime the executive wrote chapters
about his friendship with Steve Jobs he
and his wife will obey were close
friends with Steve and Lorraine Powell
jobs even spending holidays together and
vacationing in Hawaii he even writes
about standing in front of Steve Jobs
grave when the tech Visionary wife
uttered I asked him if we could trust
you and Steve said I love that guy so
there is a huge connection between Iger
and jobs who we all know has passed away
but he always stated that he one of his
biggest regrets was not coupling up with
the huge tech company so on that huge
note it is important to realize a few
things one Steve Jobs has passed and now
we have cook who is a lot more
conservative with his approach to
Acquisitions acquiring different
companies and apple and Disney although
huge conglomerates are two very
different companies although it's very
likely that Disney would still run under
its own umbrella it would have its own
CEO nothing would really change except
for who was backing Disney which would
be apple the massive tech company and
overall it would be a massive exchange
for Disney to start anew because frankly
the numbers don't lie and given the
current market trends from The Last Five
Years Apple's trading at 150 up 238
percent in the last five years in Disney
at 96 is down six percent in the same
time frame so not only has Disney not
seen in advance in the last five years
they've actually dropped six percent
overall and money is what talks yes we
love the Disney projects we love the
franchise of Star Wars Marvel Pixar and
many numerous other Disney characters
who we all know and love but at the end
of the day it's all about making a
profit and if Disney doesn't start
finding a way to progress to grow in the
market well they're gonna have to make
some drastic changes and that very well
could be selling the company it's also
important to mention that Apple has done
business with Disney before in fact
Disney bought the jobs run Pixar in 2006
for 7.4 billion dollars and we are all
very well aware of how successful Pixar
has managed to be over the years so a
lot of interesting developments will be
happening over the next two years with
Disney and we're going to try to keep as
close to the pulse of everything going
on as possible here on the channel
because although we primarily talk about
Marvel what happens with Disney event
actually affects Marvel in fact we're
still waiting to hear the immediate
effects of Bob Iger stepping in for Bob
chapek whether that's going to be a
cutback on Disney plus projects since it
is widely believed right now that Bob
chapek was forcing a mandated quota
which basically is telling us that all
of these extra projects we're getting
with the fluffer episodes and the
dissatisfied CJ animation and
storytelling from Disney plus which is a
pretty high complaint coming from fans
from you guys over the last two years
while we've been in phase four it's all
been from pressure so that they could
push Disney plus and to continue to grow
its resources and the money that Disney
plus is bringing in for the company
again this is a company that as a whole
is potentially struggling to be
marketable and there are a lot of
different branches that Disney owns a
lot of different things that they're
maintaining and that they're trying to
create so just because Marvel and Pixar
are doing very very well doesn't mean
that other areas of Disney's massive
tree of finances and monies and
businesses is being as equally
successful so all of the success we've
been seeing from Marvel has to carry the
weight financially of the other Ventures
that Disney has had that haven't been so
successful and that's a real bummer and
hopefully Bob Iger has a plan to bring
them forward in the next two years so
that it doesn't necessarily have to
resort to selling Disney and losing some
of that creative control adding another
boss over the list of the CEOs and all
the others we have there because with
more people in charge comes more
creative differences and more potential
issues but it's also nice to remember
that with apple in charge maybe there'd
be more money in deeper pockets and more
opportunities for expansion and a better
organization of how Disney is running
things now my personal opinion I don't
think Bob iger's first plan is to sell
to Tim Cook I think originally had Steve
Jobs still been around this would be
something he'd be looking at but I think
he wants Disney to still remain it's own
company this is one of the most
recognizable brands on the planet Earth
and it's very understandable that this
is a company that should remain itself
and although it does run and own a lot
of different properties it would be kind
of sad for me to see Disney passed on to
Apple and for Apple to be calling all
the shots from that point forward but
your guys's opinions are also important
so let me know in the comment section
down below what you think of this news
if Apple were to buy Disney do you think
that that would ultimately be a good
thing or would that be the end of Disney
and potentially Marvel as we know it let
me know your guys's thoughts in the
comment section down below don't forget
to subscribe and turn on that
notification Bell so you don't miss out
on any of the other major moving
television news updates happening daily
right here on the cosmic Wonder